the next question I want to raise is
well this stuff here how's it calculated
and I'm going to pose that question to
you guys how do you think they work out
how are they going to work out in 2014
a two point two five years is the life
expectancy of a person in Australia on
average what are your concern now the
census is a very natural place around
life to go because with it all this has
got a pretty wide information so
therefore you'd expect like acceptance
is one of the only things that we could
know that is like comprehension however
I will point out to you really quickly
this cannot be census information copied
before we get to what it actually is so
you know pelson is a center segment let
me tell you let me tell you how often it
doesn't happen it's our every year it
does not happen every single year so
whatever this is it's not census
information okay secondly if you be with
your parents with this affiliate their
business they just ask your husband and
what do they ask is anyone here about
the diet you put it up as I measure you
get from the center this I'm your HD I
agree okay so the HDI is very closely
related to this thinner it's another
metric that people use Detroit compare
countries is that kind of thing I give
unique the life expectancy from
someone's life dead right
okay so life expectancy this is an
import menu underneath we're kind of
calculated I wish you right now
life expectancy versus
with different mentality yes how is this
route this thing hug each other for me
okay go to the mall I'm at the airport a
government people the technical term is
the registry of births deaths and
marriages okay
these are the people could issue you a
bit regional accuracy they don't the age
of every person when they die right has
to be reported was supposed to be
anything and so for that reason if you
just have a look at in a particular time
at what age are people dying some people
are going to die
or the risk obviously some people will
die younger sadly and then you're going
to have a what's that shape speak back a
couple topics by you're going to have
this distribution right this is also
normal but you normal distribution
thinking you're going to get something
like this right you're going to get what
you said to be a normal distribution
because it's just like many other things
something which we base which has
variation and Elvis of registers did it
and then from that it can track this BC
called a life table that's actually a
really important frame of life table the
life table includes just prevent this
numbers of our ages and values of
different factors that contribute to
people passing away whether they wear
their classic early or later well okay
so if we know the average age sorry if
we do the ages in whichever to talk to
you why you can just work that knowledge
but that's pretty much it so kind of
calculated that's the basic essence or
the way these numbers come from the
other important question for us is what
the factors that lead it to this now
we've already discussed a small number
of these for instance we talked about we
talked about fertility rate okay by the
way there's at least two ways in which
fertility rate connects to life
expectancy right we notice the fertility
rate what and life expectancy in
why what it did more resource
mentholated people so you could say you
could say if there are less people being
bored there's less of a street or the
resources of society so we can care for
people better that's plausible if not
usually identify it as a reason because
that takes too long to actually have an
effect that makes sense right
it takes that well rough-looking okay
totally it's still an idea here what is
it there's so many factors I know that
my grandparents could they wanted kids
local farms and maybe left when you have
more money or you're more stable you
have Japanese so for example I my
parents come from families where there
were eight and ten children respectively
okay and one of the reasons fat is
because they knew well they just didn't
have enough money that public education
is not a thing right so we're just going
to need people to work it's going to
need people work now think about this
what that correlates to is actually this
you see this if your country overall is
poorer and so therefore people are you
know children are going to be born and
we're going to press them into work
there's a pretty normal thing 810
basically the first half of the children
get all this no schooling they just work
so that the second half can actually
have an education and potentially go to
another country if you've got nothing to
do that like my favor again so there's a
correlation here between you know that
word by the way I'm not just throwing
that out as a random word as a specific
idea there's a correlation between
fertility rate in GDP right as this
increases we have the opportunity for
this to decrease we don't need to have
as many children and so therefore we can
final worry to them we'll have more
money and they will survive for longer
be a better health care okay one of the
factors that we often don't think about
and anyone who has I mean this is just a
I hate to pick this up at it the most
obvious example anyone who has family is
manga media I have a quality friends
they would go back right and you know we
would think I'm pretty average hype here
and then they go back to India and they
look like giant wine
same genetic maybe the literally fly
family of my cousins or whatever right
but the nutrition again came back to
this it's so different that people are
just they're just short up it's more
because they just don't have the caloric
intake to actually be healthier right so
all of these things are all
interconnected so what do you say
factors right the first thing I wish to
know and I just mentioned a few just
there right there are a lot of them
there are multiple factors they all
contribute the key question for us
mathematically is what's the correlation
between any of these can we think about
life expectancy versus the GDP can we
figure out life expectancy u-verse say
the level of education that a person has
laugh expectancy verse we think our
spending on health that a government
does all of these things contribute and
if you graph them against each other
the closer the correlation is the more
reason there is for us to target that as
an idea is it already pushin - because I
honestly the open textbooks
I can't done that do that now I just
want to put you to any level what it
looks like
okay so here's 13-inch now what the
service expects of us is to be able to
look at data related to life expectancy
and be able to interpret it okay
so these kinds of things you have seen
before but it's kind of like erm I've
never seen it exactly like this what are
we looking at right now number one
you've got two graphs what's the
difference between X time very good so
we're looking at this and then 10 years
forward okay but then within each graph
you've got lots of different subsections
okay for example uh there's green and
there's red what's that about okay
actually agenda you can see why if you
just have a look at the numbers why they
pull that out right gender is a huge
predictor of your life expectancy okay
in fact there's a lot of there's a lot
of research and spins on into you know
if people get married so I add the vast
majority of people do then we'll get
married if the Y passes away first the
husband does or the widower isn't far
behind but the reverse is not true
usually right if the husband passed away
the widow could sometimes live for 10 to
20 30 years afterwards
so this contributes while there's a lot
of well this is where the debate is
right so you can see why they pulled
that out so we looked at graph one graph
- we looked at each half and how they're
different what about as you go down the
graph what's changing why this is
increasing what's it increasing in
relation to what it rolled up
yeah very good right over here okay so
then you can ask the question everybody
talked to you last lesson read the
record about correlation versus
causation okay do you speak real
questions Jen you a question do you
think having more of an education that
actually causes your life expectancy to
increase yeah okay I go pause for a
lobby said yes
give me a reason give me one reason
obviously no do concern Justice as you
completed high school it doesn't mean
that your if your family it's about how
much money your family has known how
much Lincoln's a fight because what if
you forgot like of some like major
disease and you need to pay like God for
medical treatment if they have that you
people live longer if someone has the
same buddy and I should tell you to
clean plus whatever everyone has much
money to pay for that so diarrhea okay
alright so this is point she in that
education is not like some magic wand
okay it's not as though I have eternal
illness quick put me into University
does not like that but what the same
time funny unemployed was at the same
time exclusively to recover you gonna
say you're sort of thanks to again
because you're gonna have had a higher
light levels education you like more
aware like for example like smoking
drugs like yes that helps them what
happens whatever you like your bases
okay this is very true but it's a
genuine like them actually climb up here
right now so we're up as we have more
education you are literally
understanding more about the way the
world works more about the way money and
health what which actually is going to
cause I'll absences moment you are
always going to
I was actually gonna feel like it
comments direct correlations but it has
a moment correlation because like we
look at like education and present even
well-educated has like a high you chain
who not being employee and then a person
that you can employ to the hotel but not
having enough money to people like
happening and groups and you which can
easily affect your life expectancy
laughing so by the way I mean this is
one reason was to print inserted
obviously I have biased but is one of
reasons why governments around the world
and NGOs non-government organizations
where they're trying to work on life
expectancy in developing countries what
are the first places they go is
education and schooling because the
Keystone that we there's so many other
things there are identify support your
the idea okay
you can see how to read it by in
comparison and so you can see okay well
what was the difference in life
expectancy in 1936 between the most
educated and the least educated males
where am I looking at the graph when
you're this grants and I'm comparing the
least educated here 47 with the most
educators for so seven years which by
the way is a really long time to like if
you think about it the age of it that's
a huge gap okay later on as you go over
the page you're going to have a look at
the difference between different
ethnicities we live in country
do you guys know about the life
expectancy gap between average of the
solitary Island people and everyone else
is massive it's enormous
and what I advise you do is if you go go
ahead and go to the Google where I got
this by the way it's just if you google
life expectancy Australia it'll just
generate this for you but if you stroll
down teeny teeny bit what you see is in
sharing Institute of Health and Welfare
I highly recommend this will help you
answer any questions but it's just
interesting and important stuff for you
to know if you go to their website
it breaks down life tables as I was
pointing out of course a whole bunch of
different things different countries
different types of you could say
Aboriginal chocolate on other people
are specifically named occurrences to
sitting target so you can see not that
successful moments here we go you can
see some of the data here right it's
even more significance of the different
genders which is a really big deal
that's like biological difference and
here you can see ten point six years
lower than that at the non-indigenous
population I said seven years is a lot
almost eleven that's crazy